Vi ricordate quando è l'ultima volta che
vi siete annoiati non mi rispondete non
me lo dite non me lo dite adesso
Probabilmente avrà coinciso con la
batteria del vostro smartphone al 1%. o
probabilmente con il vostro smartphone
spento
la noia è una di quelle cose che abbiamo
perso in questi anni e sulla noia
torneremo e torneremo tanto ma il nostro
viaggio inizia da qui inizia
da qui dalla domanda che ci poniamo più
spesso una delle domande che ci ha posto
più spesso Facebook il social network
per eccellenza A cosa stai pensando
quante volte abbiamo risposto a questa
domanda A cosa stai pensando Cristiano
perché Facebook parla in terza persona
ci chiede con il nostro nome e cognome a
cosa pensiamo prima di Facebook prima
dei social che conosciamo Oggi prima
della cosiddetta Social media era la
nostra Second Life era una seconda vita
fatta di altri nomi fatta di pseudonimi
di soprannomi ci sono tanti giovani e
magari non se lo ricorderanno noi non ci
chiamavamo con il nostro nome nome e
cognome Ora invece parliamo con il
nostro nome esprimiamo pensieri sapete
cosa vuol dire esprimere dei pensieri è
una cosa innocente Cosa volete che resti
dei pensieri noi quando dobbiamo
giustificarci o dobbiamo dire a qualcuno
che in fondo non conta quello che
diciamo
tendiamo a dire ma lo so solo lo so solo
pensando ad alta voce è solo un pensiero
e nel frattempo mentre pensavamo su
facebook mentre Pensavamo sui social è
successo che abbiamo lasciato tante
tracce abbiamo lasciato tante cose
scritte e molte di queste cose scritte
resteranno resteranno nel tempo
il mio viaggio inizia
circa nel 2008 nel 2008 probabilmente è
l'anno in cui noi conosciamo i social
network per quello che sono diventati in
questi anni mi trovavo in vacanza nei
paesi balcanici era in Montenegro e ho
conosciuto molti ragazzi e molte ragazze
che mi parlavano di un social network
chiamato Facebook io allora non ero
iscritto a Facebook non avevo non
conoscevo molte persone molti italiani
iscritti a Facebook loro lo utilizzavano
per tornare in contatto con tanti amici
che durante l'epoca del dell'università
avevano perso di vista
erano gli anni successivi alla guerra
nell'ex Jugoslavia
e molti di loro utilizzavano quel Social
per ritrovare amici croati amici serbi
amici sloveni erano un'opportunità per
loro noi italiani non avevamo vissuto
una guerra ma in compenso potevamo
finalmente tornare in contatto con i
nostri amici delle elementari
ora ci vorrebbero 5-6 minuti per
individuare chi sono io nella foto ma
credo che non sia così importante però
c'è una cosa importante in questa
fotografia
ed è il fatto che la simbologia resta e
a volte la simbologia non racconta la
verità vi svelo l'arcano io sono l'unico
senza grembiule è detta così
sembrerebbe che io sia un ribelle che io
sia uno di quei bambini Stay foolish che
non vogliono rispettare le regole In
realtà avevo fatto qualcosa che è
praticamente mi aveva costretto a
togliere il grembiule e mi ero spaccato
la testa da qualche minuto
sanguinavo e quindi mi avevano tolto il
grembiule ma io non sono un bambino non
ero un bambino ribelle e non sono
ribelle Adesso però quella foto è
rimasta così e noi negli anni abbiamo
ritrovato i nostri amici delle
elementari le abbiamo chiesto cosa fai
Che lavoro fai Ti sei sposato dove vivi
e così è iniziata la nostra storia sui
social network
negli anni Abbiamo condiviso tante cose
abbiamo condiviso pensieri come abbiamo
detto abbiamo condiviso storie emozioni
canzoni film gusti e questo ha finito
per fare il gioco di chi Quel Social
aveva creato perché il gioco di chi Quel
Social ha creato era creare più
polarizzazione possibile
alla fine ci siamo ritrovati in un luogo
dove la polarizzazione comandava
abbiamo discusso di vaccini abbiamo
discusso di guerre abbiamo discusso di
politica e ci siamo accorti che più
litigavamo e più i nostri post venivano
visti più litigi più pubblicità più
polarizzazione più pubblicità
è gratis e lo sarà sempre
questa era la promessa la promessa della
social media era proprio io ti do
qualcosa di gratuito Tu non preoccuparti
di altro se non di lasciarmi tutto
quello che puoi tutti i tuoi gusti tutte
le tue tutti i tuoi pareri tutte le tue
discussioni Io nel frattempo ne
approfitto per fare un po' di pubblicità
Ma che sarà mai e la polarizzazione non
ha fatto altro che toglierci una cosa
fondamentale ed è quella che vi ho
citato All'inizio la noia Non sappiamo
più annoiarci
e oggi non sapersi annoiare vuol dire
non avere quell'ozium creativo che tanto
piaceva ai nostri padri Forse qualcosa
di più che padri Latini Greci che
cercavano la noia
la creatività ha bisogno della noia e
non solo la creatività noi della nostra
generazione siamo cresciuti anche
dovendo fronteggiare grandi momenti di
noia oggi se andate da un medico o se
aspettate una persona sotto casa
Probabilmente userete lo Smartphone per
superare quel momento di noi
invece
l'interesse di chi ha creato i social
network era proprio quella di non farci
annoiare mai è una cosa tremenda non
annoiarsi mai
siamo diventati ci siamo Iper
personalizzati i social si sono Iper
personalizzati Ogni esperienza
collettiva è diventata un'esperienza
individuale
la social media era quella che abbiamo
vissuto fino a poco fa e che forse Oggi
per fortuna stiamo per superare è quella
dell'esperienza individuale anche quando
è collettiva se andate ad un concerto se
andate in una partita di calcio se
andate una manifestazione in piazza
probabilmente vi interesserà più la
vostra parte quella individuale quella
che raccontate quella che condividete
che non quella collettiva quella della
conoscenza quella della vera
condivisione
dopo Facebook
è arrivato un altro social
che dello stesso gruppo ovviamente che è
stato acquisito dallo stesso gruppo
e che ha mantenuto la promessa che ha
nel nome soltanto per pochi mesi sapete
che cosa vuol dire Instagram Ci avete
mai pensato Instagram vuol dire Insta
più gram una foto in quel momento
non una realtà mistificata non la realtà
mistificata che ci raccontano gli
influencer o che noi abbiamo voluto
raccontare in tutti questi anni
Instagram è nato per essere qualcosa di
molto simile al birial di oggi per chi
lo conosce fai una foto e condividila e
invece noi abbiamo finito per filtrare
le nostre vite per modificarle per
rendere sempre più belle più belle di
quello che erano e questo ha creato
un'ansia sociale altissima al di là
della possibilità di guadagnare di
diventare influencer di diventare
content Creator Siamo finiti in un loop
di
un invidia in cui noi stessi siamo i
primi protagonisti perché noi stessi
abbiamo bisogno di raccontare una vita
che sia più bella della nostra
quando chi gestisce i social Quindi chi
ha inventato i social ha capito che noi
iniziavamo a condividere meno ha creato
le Stories ha creato la possibilità di
mettere qualcosa che sparisce dopo 24
ore e Voi direte e che sarà mai 24 ore
mica lascio un ricordo e poi c'è oggi ci
ritroviamo nei siti di gossip delle
Stories messe e tolte dopo cinque minuti
forse uno
che possono influenzare una vita possono
influenzare un rapporto
durano solo 24 Ore
in realtà durano anche molto meno
abbiamo utilizzato gli smartphone in una
maniera
eccessiva
Eppure facendo un passo indietro Sono
andato a
ricercare un film che probabilmente
avrete visto in tanti Chi ha visto
Ritorno al futuro Bene benissimo
Ritorno al futuro è un film del 1985
prevede tantissime cose che sono
realmente successe Il Ritorno al futuro
c'è gente che paga con qualcosa che è
molto simile al POS Il Ritorno al futuro
c'è un presidente americano di colore Il
Ritorno al futuro c'è una persona che
somiglia molto a Trump anche
Il Ritorno al futuro ci sono le video
call
Martin il padre di Martin mcfly viene
licenziato
You are Fire viene licenziato con un fax
ma attraverso una videocall ci sono
tantissime cose che ci siamo portati
anche oggi i Google Glass o qualcosa di
molto simile ma non ci sono gli
smartphone nessuno aveva pensato che
saremmo stati 24 ore attaccati ad un
solo oggetto
e questa è stata la social media era
ora ci apprestiamo a qualcosa di molto
diverso
la post social media era è già in atto
in realtà è arrivata dopo la pandemia
con la richiesta di un maggiore
equilibrio da parte delle persone oggi
le persone chiedono
più privacy Chiedono una condivisione
migliore che chiedono che sia rispettato
il proprio tempo
la posta social media era è fatta di
nicchie sarà fatta di social network
magari probabilmente anche con una
subscription quindi pago qualcosa
piuttosto che dare i miei dati e i miei
numeri ad una pubblicità Sarà fatto di
sarà fatta di Community più rispettose
dove non è l'algoritmo a comandare ma il
rapporto e soprattutto sarà fatta da
un'inclusione tra le generazioni Ecco
questo è probabilmente uno dei temi più
importanti più rilevanti i social hanno
definitivamente
scollato le generazioni hanno
definitivamente fatto sì che le
generazioni Non si parlassero più
ci chiamano kringe si chiamano boomer ci
chiamano millennials non sappiamo
neanche più come ci chiamano
Non sappiamo più la differenza tra chi è
dell'agenzia ed è più inclusivo e chi
invece considera ancora il lavoro una
schiavitù ci sono gruppi su Facebook che
si chiamano Ma che ne sanno i 2000
operazione nostalgia tutto è basato
tutto è basato
sull'esclusività ma non l'esclusività
come lusso l'esclusività come esclusione
la post social media era deve lavorare
sull'inclusione e quando parliamo di
inclusione non parliamo soltanto di
gender non parliamo soltanto come giusto
che sia di Popoli parliamo anche di età
di generazione siamo nell'epoca in cui
per chi fa marketing e per chi fa
comunicazione il primo criterio del
target crollato uomo o donna ora deve
crollare il secondo l'età perché non è
più possibile
creare queste divisioni per età
divisioni di linguaggio divisioni di
pensiero
e sarà all'epoca in cui il network sarà
sostituito dalla Community c'è una
grandissima differenza tra network e
Community social media Network
Provate a chiedere su Facebook a
qualcuno di venire a casa vostra a
pitturare le pareti
probabilmente nessuno vi dirà di sì
perché un network nel network siamo
connessi ma oggi essere connessi nella
post social media era Non basterà più
noi abbiamo bisogno di Community le
Community sono quegli spazi in cui
accade qualcosa Le Community puntano al
care
non puntano alla connessione abbiamo
bisogno di spazi ancora più
personalizzati dove davvero si possa
entrare in contatto con le persone
conoscerle condividere delle cose e
prenderci cura di loro o far sì che
qualcuno si prenda cura di noi
stanno arrivando anni complessi
sono gli anni dell'intelligenza
artificiale del chat GPT
molti di questi strumenti sostituiranno
delle persone sostituiranno dei
professionisti
a patto che quei professionisti e quelle
persone
capiscano Come si usano Questi strumenti
a me piace dire che la hai non potrà
assolutamente fare a meno della agei la
Human Intelligence
senza Human intelligence senza una
cultura generale
Questi strumenti non andranno lontano
l'intelligenza artificiale oggi non è in
grado di fare connessione non è in grado
di raccontare aneddoti non è in grado
soprattutto di raccontare storie le
storie sono e resteranno per sempre la
tecnologia più persuasiva che abbiamo
E a proposito di questo vi lascio con
una storia
è una storia che parla di vampiri
è una storia che parla di energie
svuotate
Pablo Picasso era un vampiro
lo dice la sua biografia e nella sua
biografia lo dice la nipote Marina
Marina dice che Pablo Picasso era un
vampiro Perché spremeva le persone
esattamente come spremeva i tubetti di
colore li svuotava di energia nessuno se
n'è accorto perché tutti volevano stare
vicino a Pablo Picasso perché Pablo
Picasso nel networking rappresentava il
massimo
per chi faceva parte della sua cerchia
non se n'è accorto nessuno fino a quando
non se n'è accorto uno scultore si
chiamava Constantin brancusi
se il nome non vi dice niente sappiate
che brancusi era originario dei Carpazi
era rumeno e i rumeni sanno riconoscere
i vampiri
i rumeni se ne accorgono subito di
quando qualcuno è un vampiro e aveva
deciso di non frequentare Pablo Picasso
perché ogni volta che tornava da una
conversazione con Pablo Picasso si
sentiva non arricchito ma svuotato di
energie Ecco nei prossimi anni noi
dobbiamo ritrovare persone
Community social network che non ci
svuotino di energie come hanno fatto
finora come hanno fatto nella social
media era Ma che ci diano un'energia in
più una forza in più
e se mi chiedete A cosa sto pensando
adesso
sto pensando che la post social media
era è già iniziata